dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly shown IFA here when I
open my inbox today I was greeted by a
huge deluge of messages about wavelet
well first it's great to see that so
many people are excited about these
inventions and second may all your
wishes come true as quickly as this one
so here we go this piece of work is
about generating audio waveforms for
text-to-speech and more text-to-speech
basically means that we have a voice
reading whatever we have written down
the difference in this work is however
that it can synthesize these samples in
someone's voice provided that we have
training samples of this person speaking
the avocado is a pear-shaped fruit with
leathery skin smooth edible flesh in a
large stone the avocado is a pear-shaped
fruit with leathery skin smooth edible
flesh and a large stone the avocado is a
pear-shaped fruit with leathery skin
smooth edible flesh and a large stone
the avocado is a pear-shaped fruit with
leathery skin smooth edible flesh in a
large stone it also generates wave forms
sample by sample which is particularly
perilous because we typically need to
produce these at the rate of sixteen to
twenty-four thousand samples per second
and as we listen to the TV radio and
talk to each other several hours a day
the human ear and brain is particularly
suited to processing this kind of signal
if the result is off by only the
slightest amount we immediately
recognize it it is not using a recurrent
neural network which is typically suited
to learn sequences of things and is
widely used for sound synthesis it is
using a convolutional neural network
which is quite surprising because it is
not meant to process sequences of data
that change in time however this variant
contains an extension that is able to do
that they call this extension dilated
convolutions and they open up the
possibility of making large skips in the
input data so we have a better global
view of it if we were working in
computer vision it would be like
increasing the receptive field of the
eye so we can see the entire landscape
and not only a tree on a photograph it
is also a bit like the temporal
coherence problem we have talked about
earlier taking all this into
consideration results in more consistent
outputs over larger timescales so the
technique knows what it had done several
seconds ago also training a
convolutional neural network is a walk
in the park compared to a recurrent
neural network really cool and the
result speed all existing widely used
techniques by a large margin one of
these is the concatenative technique
which builds sentences from a huge
amount of small speech fragments these
have seen a ton of
improvements during the years but the
outputs are still robotic and it is
noticeable that we are not listening to
human but a computer the deepmind guys
also report that quote notice that non
speech sounds such as breathing and
mouth movements are also sometimes
generated by wavenet this reflects the
greater flexibility of a raw audio model
and quote
the blue lagoon is a 1980 American
romance an adventure film directed by
Randal Kleiser
the blue lagoon is a 1980 American
romance and adventure film directed by
Randal Kleiser
aspects of the sublime in English poetry
and painting 1770 to 1850 aspects of the
sublime in English poetry and painting
1770 to 1850 at the same time I'd like
to note that in the next few episodes it
may be that my voice is a bit different
but don't worry about that it may also
happen that I am on a vacation but new
episodes and voice samples pop up on the
channel please don't worry about that
either
everything is working as intended they
also experimented with music generation
and the results are just stunning
you
I don't know what to say these difficult
problems these impenetrable walls
crumble one after another as deep mind
takes on them insanity their blog post
and the paper are both really
well-written make sure to check them out
they are both linked in the video
description box I wager that artistic
style transfer for sound and instruments
is not only coming but it will be here
soon I imagine that will play a guitar
and it will sound like a harp and will
be able to sing something in Lady Gaga's
voice and intonation I've also seen
someone pitching the idea of creating
audiobooks automatically with such a
technique Wow
I travel a lot and then almost always on
the go so I personally would love to
have such audiobooks I have linked to
the mentioned machine learning reddit
thread in the description box as always
there's lots of great discussion and
ideas there it was also reported that
the algorithm currently takes 90 minutes
to synthesize one second of sound
waveforms you know the drill one
follow-up paper down the line it will
take only a few minutes a few more
papers down the line it will be real
time just think about all these
advancements what a time we are living
in and I am extremely excited to present
them all to you fellow scholars in two
minute papers make sure to leave your
thoughts and ideas in the comment
section we love reading them thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time
you